so now it's time to reveal the new hotel
to David and Sukie and their team
[Music]
welcome to new hotel Chester you're no
longer hidden on the Main Street now
customers locals identifying that it is
a hotel is it big enough for you David
yeah I think it's really really great
there is the biggest marketing tool
you'll ever need should we have a look
inside
yeah I'm looking forward to seeing what
Gordon has done with the inside of the
hotel you ready
[Music]
Wow jumping that's going at least this
is definitely lovely lovely love I love
it
Jonas the drab and the dullness now this
room has character isn't this beautiful
I'm genuinely thrilled if I could I'd do
a somersault backwards and then if
Gordon had let me out kiss him and even
if he does and I may drag him in and
give him a big old kiss right on the
damn lips Megan nice to see you happy
it's more than I can have hoped for and
it seems to be the beginning of the end
of our struggle do you think the parents
are those 20,000 students in the
university we want to stay here now yes
[Music]
please I'd like to welcome you all to
your stunning big gardener this is what
I call a beer garden damn
modern benches so we have communal
benches as well large parties families
additional space that is why we take
advantage off Study Fellowship has a
nice beautiful I love it you go to the
gazebo we have the most amazing local
beers craft beers on well and these
stunning craft beers that can rotate the
local beers to sort of promote stuff
locally it's the beer garden is awesome
I'm gonna christen it myself and
somebody's gonna have to carry me out of
it before we open the doors to the
public there's one more thing I'd like
to show you please come with me love its
garden out here welcome to you
Hotel Chester's stunning beer gardens
foods this hotel is in a vibrant college
town in the heart of Mississippi so I've
created a menu that will attract a
younger crowd and highlights suddenly
comfort food gone is the fusion
confusion Sookie I'm sorry all gone good
southern food fits the location how can
we be in Starkville and not have
stunning fire green tomatoes next now we
are Easter bacon po-boy 5 crispy oysters
crispy bacon with a stunning spicy
Remillard
and Gordon's burger he's a chef comes up
with some stunning recipes for burgers
this burger recipe is featured at Planet
Hollywood in Vegas and it is to die for
the new menu complements the state of
Mississippi I think it really suits the
beer garden wonderful wonderful idea
Sookie I have something for you that's
gonna make your life in the kitchen a
whole lot easier
they were the one second please
I've got someone I'd like to introduce
you to someone whom very special with
two unique assistants come through
please
say hello to Enrico Williams now she'll
beat Hotel Chester's new head chef this
lady is a very experienced chef and she
absolutely knows her stuff I'm covering
Enriquez salary I'm taking care of that
until this place picks up and you can
afford to keep it yourself beautiful
having Sookie in the kitchen kind of
broke my heart everyday so I'm really
looking forward to getting to know the
chef and her apprentices and giving them
all the support I possibly can Sookie I
want you to keep cooking but I want you
to have a bit of fun with it and here's
how it's gonna work
Sookie's rebutted grilled skewers
chicken beef shrimp garlic ginger soy
ranek that's a robot a it's a personal
touch I love it
I love to change rubato is classic
Japanese barbecue when you think of a
robata grill you think marinade is
Japanese style is easy to execute and
you don't want it cut a little bit slack
in the kitchen that gives the kitchen a
bit of time all of you sit down and tuck
in right there's one more little thing
going to show you in this place
beautiful then gorgeous pool they're
both you come in for two seconds
[Music]
now living in that tiny room with no
windows is not way to live
so this is your new apartment I rented
this for the next six months I'm sure
when the business kicks off you'll have
sufficient funds to render Sparrer oh I
love it
Oh complain kitchen lounge how pretty
look at the bedrooms through there
beautiful this is just what we really
need it for day and me to get away some
time out there's yours thank you thank
you again that's awesome I'm just damn
flabbergasted actually being on sites
and not having time house of your hotel
you were blind to the potential on your
doorstep was ridiculous we thought
Gordon was just coming here to help us
with the business he ended up being
helping us emotionally our marriage he
very much wanted for us to be together
and that was so lovely I've heard am
also more question another really really
nice yes thank you again now I'm gonna
hurt you okay
bend some closer time together now you
deserve good night and good luck
all right bye Gordon